[Musique]
j'avais quatre ans quand j'ai pris
l'avion pour la première fois c'était
vous c'était merveilleux
à différer de mes parents je suis parti
pour un autre voyage ce voyage m'a
brutalement sorti mon innocence
à quelques mois de juin 18 ans
je suis partie cette fois ci en voyage
mais pour apprendre à dakar pour étudier
pour mes études
en 2010 j'ai entamé un autre voyage
celui là vers l'amour
vers le mariage vers la vieille est
ensemble et moi nous avons réussi un
bond à 1 2 puis à 3 est toutefois 5
nous avons les idées en moldavie gabon à
madagascar
en 2018 sans rentrer au burkina faso on
nous installe la moule que pas mal en
tout cas pas l'amour - journée
nous étions
2019 sapé comme jamais j'allais à un
abus un rendez vous important pour moi
et je me suis retrouvé soudainement
moins aux urgences
aux urgences d'une vie privée de voir
êtes-vous hurlant de douleur
une onde de douleur et j'ai terminé sous
investis sous intraveineuse de galement
de l'anti inflammatoire et enfin de
bayonne parce que plus rien ne me calmer
cette urgence la mam brutalement sorti
de ma résiliation ou montagny parce que
oui à un monde où les gens maîtrisent ni
ma mère par contre elle ne s'est jamais
désigné j'ai fait les bains de vapeur
avec des décoctions dont vous n'imaginez
même pas nous et loser
j'ai fait des injections du de 20
minutes
20 minutes avec une aiguille plantée
dans le corps
je crois aussi que sincèrement le fait
d'avoir pu enfanter malgré tout mme
avait rempli de gratitude parce que moi
malgré tout j'avais pu avoir un enfant
et parce que deux médecins différents
ont dit qu'il était impossible au vu de
l'état de mes ouvert quand je puisse
avoir un enfant sans traitement
préalable
mais ma fille et est arrivé
c'était mon imac notre miracle
puis sont arrivés
deux autres êtres d'egypte ou
que j'appelle des bonus lui fit amis
mes bonus finale
en 2020
j'ai entamé un autre voyage à tunis
cette fois ci une énième fois et c'est
l'accord enfin on a pu mettre un nom sur
ce que j'avais
à des lots mis aux
ut ligne diffusent
un des lots mis aux aidants son prénom
à des lots mis aux esprits nos
endométriose est son nom
j'ai crié en femme enfin je ne suis pas
folle je ne suis pas parano je ne suis
pas une paresseuse je ne suis pas
hypocondriaque je ne suis pas une
chercheuse non j'ai même développer une
tolérance à la douleur qui pouvait aussi
apprendre je suis malade et sa maman
enfin
le mieux pourquoi vous baigner tout ça
et que je vous raconte un voyage du pic
d'un bombe un voyage étrange
jean-marc tout d'abord pour eux 30 pour
trait jours d'un merveilleux voyage
région je suis moi où je paie tizi ouzou
choses bougent toujours punk 13 jours je
vois le chocolat chaud entre autres très
jour je le vis pleinement
puis arrive dijoux
dix jours tu symbolise ce qu'on appelle
les symptômes prémenstruels
alors comme mon corps c'est que j'aime
les grandes expériences élite est il
exerce sur - toutes les combinaisons
possibles de mots pour me préparer à
l'avant ce don sans suivre ou de cendre
ne rangent nous tous balmont roba tueur
troubles de l'humeur
mais en fait ces dix jours ne sont là
que pour annoncer qu'une enquête interne
qui se prépare
puis arrive ces sept derniers jours
l'apothéose
je vais me déprimer ça comme un
magnétisme grave
combiné à des pros battu à son monde le
tout accompagné de contraction d'un
nichon et même là je crois que vous n'y
êtes pas encore
alors les mots que je vous ai cité
viennent maintenant en pour l'influent
donc moins cinq branches modeste pour un
abonnement et cette fois ci tous ceux
qui la montrent un enseignement est
dense
et puis la fatique
cette fatigue je crois qu'au delà de
tout c'est cette fatigue l'un qui
méprisent moralement le plus parce que
je suis et cuisine je suis vidé de toute
énergie pendant ces sept jours là je
survis
voilà comment se passe typiquement un
mois pour moi même le lendemain de ces
sept jours donc le premier jour des
treize jours j'ai en bolivie et le cycle
en quoi est toujours chaque
[Musique]
mois j'ai près jour dans le monde à
l'eau - où est au top de moi même alors
comprenez moi je ne puisse pas ouvrir ma
vie de négativité et de personnes
négatif je m'excuse auprès d'eux si vous
en faites partie je puise en moi la
positivité qu'il me faut mais je
m'entoure aussi de personnes positives
et du réel impact sur
c'est parce que aussi je sais à quel
point chaque minute chaque seconde
compte que j'ai décidé d'accompagner
d'autres personnes pour déployer leur
potentiel pour connaître leurs missions
de vie pourquoi maximiser leur talent
parce que oui il en faut du talent
pourquoi mon team is est très jour de
vide en moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'endométriose
touche 190 millions de femmes dans le
monde
je vous rappelle que les opiacés
contiennent de l'opium en de médicaments
contiennent de l'opium dont je peux vous
dire que je sais ce que c'est que de
planer au
sauf qu'au bout de quatre heures les
effets redescente et comme je ne peux
pas planer au pendant sept jours je les
garde pour les moments où je n'ai plus
le choix
essayer de régulariser quoi me le disent
nos règles et donc d'atténuer les
douleurs
vient aussi le des le dispositif intra
utérin
le stérilet communément appelée ainsi
qui permet de réduire les segments qui
réduisent est en traction donc ils
réduisent les douleurs il y a le
décapeptyl qu'on nous propose ici un
médicament qui coûte en 115 milles et
180 milles par mois pour un traitement
de six mois
180 milles par mois pendant six mois et
qui impose une ménopause artificielle la
ménopause artificielle qui induit des
troubles de l'humeur et du comportement
imaginez-vous ménopausées à 30 ans avec
tout ce qui va avec
et enfin
on nous propose maintenant
l'ablation de l'utérus en cas extrême
mais c'est une chose pour laquelle il
faut une préparation psychologique
importante et à mon âge je ne suis
absolument pas prête
comment se fait le diagnostic le
diagnostic se fait en général par irm
mais sous nos cieux quand on ne peut pas
on le fait par eux par échographie et on
nous dit toujours vous n'avez rien un
médecin m'a même dit madame vous devrez
chercher ailleurs les causes de votre
douleur c'est peut-être ailleurs mais
c'est pas dans votre ventre avec
l'échographie je me suis dit ailleurs où
es-tu folle fatimi
après l'irm vient la coelioscopie alors
la coelioscopie je vous explique ce que
c'est c'est cinq jolies petites roues
qu'on nous fait dans le ventre pour
aller chercher à l'intérieur de nous des
traces d'endométriose et quand il y en a
ça permet de les extraire
j'ai fait une coelioscopie
il y a un an et dix jours exactement
aujourd'hui j'en connais qui en ont fait
2 3 7
voilà ce qui s'offre à nous comme option
alors je veux vous dire à vous
que vos filles vos mères vos épouses vos
soeurs vos collègues vos attentes vos
amis qui vous disent qu'elles ont mal ou
vraiment mal
et je vais m'avancer pour vous dire
quelque chose sur l'année lé mans parce
que je suppose que c'est parce que vous
ne le savez pas que vous continuez à le
faire contrairement à ce que vous pensez
nous avons nous tous temps des balances
et des miroirs chez nous oui oui on se
voit on sait qu'on a grossi qu'on a
maigri qu'on est boursouflé on est au
courant
[Applaudissements]
on sait
je tenais à vous le dire ce soir parce
que je me suis dit que vous ne le saviez
pas puisque vous continuez
je veux maintenant parler au système
éducatif et au moins d'enseignants je
veux vous dire que
des milliers de filles quittent chaque
année le système éducatif et l'école
parce qu'elles ont tout simplement mal
au bas ventre des milliers de filles ne
viennent plus parce que aussi elles
manquent de garniture des milliers de
filles arrêtent l'école parce que elles
ne veulent pas venir chaque mois se
donner en spectacle au milieu de vous et
sous les regards moqueurs de leurs
camarades parce qu'on leur a dit quoi on
leur a dit que les règles c'est sale on
leur a dit que les règles c'est tabou on
leur a dit que les règles on n'en parle
pas on a dit que les règles ça ne doit
pas se voir donc elle reste loin des
nouveaux yeux et elle quitte l'école
alors tous les programmes pour amener
les filles à l'école devrait tenir
compte de ce point
je veux maintenant parler au monde
médical oui vous vous comme nous venons
voir pour nous rassurer
vous êtes peu à connaître cette maladie
alors une mise à niveau générale
s'impose
ceux qui la connaissent dispose de peu
de matériel pour poser un diagnostic
honnêtement l'échographie c'est pas ce
qu'il faut mais ici comme il faut être
dans le coma pour bénéficier d'une irm
et ben on tourne entre éco et éco
ceux qui ne la connaissent pas nous
plonge dans une errance de plusieurs
années on a mis 24 ans a posé un
diagnostic sur mon cas
la moyenne mondiale est de 7 j'ai battu
tous les records ben voilà au moins un
je suis ravi de voir de plus en plus sur
les plateaux à la télévision à la radio
dans les blogs sur les réseaux sociaux
des médecins prendre la parole pour en
parler des médecins et les patientes
prendre la parole pour en parler pour
parler de l'endométriose qui est méconnu
mais qui porte en touche 190 millions de
femmes dans le monde
je suis ravi qu'on en parle je suis
convaincu que avec les chercheurs que
nous avons qui cherchent et qui trouvent
peut être combiné à nos pharmacopée
traditionnelle on pourra enfin de
trouver un un soin curatif ou nous pour
nous guérir enfin ça viendra peut-être
du burkina
je veux maintenant parler aux
entreprises qui nous emploient
je sais vos doutes sur la véracité de
nos propos sont compréhensibles
mais comment être efficace
quand on a si mal comment être efficace
quand on est obligé de changer de
garnitures toutes les heures toutes les
deux heures vous ne le savez pas mais
nous portons souvent plusieurs sous
vêtements plusieurs vêtements juste pour
venir au boulot
nous recouvrons vos chaises de paille ou
de plastique et souvent des deux pour ne
pas les imbiber de notre son
comment être et fille avec de tels
équation en tête tous les jours je sais
que vous n'êtes vous ne faites pas dans
l'humanitaire je le conçois mais je veux
vous dire aussi qu'on travaille aussi
très bien par objectifs et que nos jours
de présence le jour de présence aide à
compenser largement tous nos jours
d'absence alors je vais vous demander un
peu d'indulgence parce que quand en
dépit de tout on vous dit qu'on ne peut
pas venir c'est parce qu'on ne peut
vraiment pas venir
je m'adresse maintenant à vous à nous à
ses 190 millions de personnes je veux
vous dire que on vous croit vous avez le
droit de parler de dire que vous avez
mal je veux vous dire que votre douleur
peut être entendu je veux vous dire de
ne jamais vous résigner à chercher la
cause de votre douleur à poser un
diagnostic dessus
parce que oui on nous a dit que une
femme
une femme forte ne parle pas une ford ne
se plaint par une femme ford accepte ou
en question pour que ses enfants soient
bénis demain on nous a dit qu'une femme
d'hier ne parle pas de ces douleurs pour
espérer un jour atteindre le paradis moi
je vous dis que devant le paradis là ça
va chauffer
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire d'oser parler parce
que si vous ne parlez pas celles qui
sont plus je ne le savent pas et il faut
qu'elle parle il faut qu'elle met des
mots sur ses douleurs pour qu'on sache
qu'elle existe parce que ce qui n'est
pas connue n'est pas traitée je suis
fatigué touré et je vous invite à
refuser la résignation
chaque mois je voyage entre vit et
survit chaque mois
mais dans tout ce mois là je partis je
choisis la partie la plus belle la
partie la plus agréable
pour mener le plus vos voyages qu'ils
soient
maintenant que j'ai vidé ma valise sous
vos yeux ébahis
je vais la fermer je vous laisse avec
mes mots et non avec mes mots pour
qu'ils raisonnent en vous et que vous
les portiers à d'autres je vous dis
merci
[Musique]